ninety percent of wealth is blown by the
third generation of a legacy education
is what needs to be passed down not the
assets themselves for example my
families are on it we were well off in
Iran and when the new regime came into
place They confiscated all of my
family's belongings my father came here
the United States with a thousand
dollars in a briefcase and he built his
life here because of his education he
was a doctor and within two generations
the wealth passed down is now the same
as it was there with me but it was the
skills not the assets that were
transferred from father to son if you
transfer the education you can make sure
that whatever Legacy you want to have is
passed on if you just transfer assets
without the ability to wield them they
will eventually be gone in two
generations